- By now
it's late October,
it's heading towards November,
and we've actually done
something remarkable.
We have completed what
was originally planned
as the first section
of our thru-hike.
And we've got to a
point in the river where
we're actually climbing
out of the canyon,
it's about a 3,500-foot
climb along a very obscure
and very difficult route known
as the Walter Powell Trail,
named after the brother
of John Wesley Powell
who was on that expedition
in the summer of 1869.
And when we got to
the rim of the canyon,
we met this lady.
- So this is Renea Yellowhorse.
She's a Navajo woman
who has spent her life
out on the horizontal
world of the Grand Canyon.
She lives up on, basically,
the rim up here, her family
has grazed sheep here
for hundreds of years.
She's standing in a
place where there's
one of the most impactful
development projects
that is about to happen.
And she's basically
become a voice
and a leader for this group
called Save the Confluence.
And they're fighting
to save this land
and this area of Grand Canyon.
And it's become a very
controversial issue,
it has divided the
Navajo community.
And we figure that instead of
us talking about it,
we let you hear what they
say and their voices.
- The gondola would bring
people all the way down
to the confluence
and there at the river level
they would have a
elevated walkway,
a snack bar, a
restroom facility.
Enough services to take
care of 10,000 people a day.
- You're gonna employ
an awful lot of people
in an impoverished area
and help them save
their culture.
What's better than that?
- Any idea of
disrupting this area
with your jackhammers,
with your machinery
or whatever dynamite
or explosive
you want to bring in here,
you're basically
destroying a shrine.
- The confluence,
little Colorado River
meets the Colorado River.
Where they meet, this
is where life begins,
this is what our
grandmothers tell us.
It is a sacred space,
and we don't want to see
the Disneyland on the
edge of the canyon.
- I think the view
from the bottom
gives one a perspective of
one's place in the universe.
If I were to hike down to
the bottom of the canyon
I'd have to be airvac'd out
because of my knees and ankles.
And so we're trying to
offer the average person
that below-the-rim experience.
- It's like a lot of experiences
throughout the world.
You know you're never gonna
be on the top of Everest.
We provide an incredible
visitor experience
for millions of
people every year.
But we can't provide every
experience for every person
based on their own
individual abilities.
- When I come here, I
wish to commune with
the ones that have
gone before me,
like my great-grandmother
and my father.
And know that they are
that special place.
That if the Escalade
Development comes in,
that it would dig into
the heart of our mothers,
Mother Earth, and I would
never be able to come here
to feel that way again.
(dramatic piano music)
- So we left the politics,
the stormy politics
of the Grand Escalade behind us,
'cause we had to
move downstream.
We had 500 miles to go.
We actually walked back down
through the area
that it would be
built if it were to be built
and we moved down through
the kaleidoscope of colors,
which is so famous
at the Grand Canyon,
but the reality is, once again,
we were in the situation where
you can't follow the river.
You come into sections
like the Inner Gorge
where you're constantly
getting pinned and locked up
on these different
benches of rock.
So we've left food roughly
every five to ten days
in plastic buckets.
Not a lot of food but,
so we're on a timed
schedule to get there,
but more importantly, we have
to get to water every day,
we can't carry more than
one day's worth of water.
And so we're constantly
trying to find ways
to move down canyon,
sometimes on these benches
way above the river,
but we have to get
back to the river.
- And when we get to the river
a whole new set of problems
present themselves.
It seemed like impenetrable
thickets of thorns
created by these dense groves of
acacia trees, mesquite.
And that's to say nothing of
the cactus that you encounter
and the attentiveness
that you have to apply
to avoid stepping
on these things.
And so the challenges
and the rigors
are still taking a
toll on our bodies.
We're still feeling the
impact of this environment.
The difference, however,
is that unlike in
September, we're holding up.
And in fact, we're
not only holding up,
but we're starting
to see evidence
of our personalities reemerge.
Every now and then I'd look over
and I'd see the
kind of Pete McBride
that I know and recognize.
And Pete would look over at me,
and he would see the
kind of Kevin Fedarko
that he's used to being around.
(audience laughing)
So basically what's
happening is that
we're feeling comfortable
enough in this environment
that we are reverting to
what passes for normalcy
between the two of us.
(audience laughing)
(chuckling)
- Alright, so it's now January.
We've moved all the way
down to the South Rim.
And I want you to
look at the lights
on the top of this frame.
This is where you'd
enter the South Rim,
this where 5 1/2
million visitors
come to Grand Canyon
National Park.
They do a remarkable job there.
But the lights in the distance
is where the second,
basically it's the southern
threat that's coming in.
So the gateway community
called Tusayan,
they've proposed 2,800 homes,
two million square feet
of commercial space,
a water ski park.
And what we started realizing
and what we continued
to want to explore
is what happens up
here on the rim,
how is it gonna affect
life down here below,
the water table,
the complex water table
that runs though it,
how is it gonna
affect the wildlife.
So as we move downstream,
we actually start
depending on the wildlife
in an unusual way,
mostly the sheep but also we
start following lion tracks.
For four days we
followed lion tracks
along the Esplanade layer.
But just as you think
you're starting to get
kinda Grand Canyon savvy
and get the kind of
vibe of the place,
it kicks you in the gut again.
- So winter in the
Grand Canyon announces
its arrival in the form of
a bunch of massive storms
that have rolled across, they've
rolled through the Pacific,
they've rolled across the West
Coast of the United States
and they start hitting the
Southwest, the Desert Southwest,
and when they do so,
the first thing that happens is
they hammer the temperatures
way down below zero.
And so you're huddled
in your tents at night,
you're trying to protect
your water bottles
and keep them from freezing,
and then, the storms,
they start unloading
the precipitation that
they carry in them.
And the snow begins
to fall late at night
when it's dark.
You don't really
know what's happening
except you hear
these ice crystals
landing in the
wall of your tent.
And you wake up in the
morning and you realize
that this world that
you are inside of
and suspended in has
been coated and glazed
in a layer of ice 10
to 11 inches thick,
which has rendered the business,
the imperative business
of moving downstream
toward those food caches
terrifying and
absolutely dangerous.
- [Woman] One right there.
- I don't know how to get my
feet into these.
- [Kevin] So frozen I can't
even straighten the toe.
- This is acts of desperation
in an unexpectedly
gigantic snowstorm.
(mumbles) You can't
get your insole out,
can you?
- I can't.
It's frozen in there.
- So we made it through that
area called Owl Eyes Bay.
It was probably one of the
most physically challenging,
most grueling sections
of the trip for us
on a number of levels.
I think on some points it
was a bit of a milestone
for us to get through it,
but it didn't let up.
We got through the
snow on some of them,
but the temperatures persisted.
Compared to the fall where
it was over a hundred,
it's not below zero.
We saw temperatures
of minus seven,
for a week after it hovered
around five degrees.
And I'm just gonna give
you a little backup
on the challenges
I was faced with
trying to capture this
place and our story
with one camera, with one lens,
with one tiny solar
panel and four batteries.
There is no socket to go pop
your camera to charge in.
And cameras and batteries,
they hate cold temperature,
so I basically would crawl in
when I would finally go to bed,
when I'm not trying to capture
the magnificent starlight,
I would go and I would
sleep the entire night
stashing my batteries
in my armpit or anywhere
that I could find any
shade of warmth, which
I really couldn't
because I took some
stupid sleeping bag,
I wasn't really warm enough.
But it's part of the
deal on some level.
What'd you think?
- What did I think?
(audience laughing)
Here's what I think.
I think that what
I hate the most
about working with a National
Geographic photographer
is something like this.
When you take undiluted
suffering and misery
and you weave it into
an image of beauty,
you are creating an
act of fraudulence.
(audience laughing)
This is what it's like to be me.
Huddled inside of a tent
with every stitch of
clothing I own on me,
wanting not to go outside
and this guy is flitting
around like some photo firefly
early in the morning
and late at night.
When I think back now,
it was really bad, the
hundred degree heat wave
in September, but it
didn't compare to this,
it was just so
miserable and so awful
that I don't even like to look
at this photograph 'cause--
- C'mon! C'mon!
- It triggers a
level of visual PTSD--
- Wait, whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa now. (laughs)
He gets going.
Alright, let's be
fair, there's one,
you enjoyed sections, right?
- Alright, I will admit,
yes, there were some
things that I did enjoy.
It's difficult for
me to recall them,
but as it turns out,
here's one of them,
and it occurred,
actually, I have to admit,
each and every day.
So the thing is, that like,
there is this moment that comes
after you've completed your
journey through the canyon
at the end of the day
and you've finally
stopped moving
and you've set up camp.
And you heat up some food,
and you get something
hot into your belly.
And you're feeling this
delicious sense of relaxation,
and then what happens is
that you lean back
and you stare up
and you realize that something
extraordinary is happening.
You are reminded
that the Grand Canyon
is graced by something
exceptional each
and every night.
You are inside of an
abyss that is a mile deep,
one of the greatest
environments on earth,
a place that has been
polished and carved out
by the greatest river
in the Southwest
that is still running
through its bottom
thousands of feet below you,
and you realize that that river
is reflected in a second
river that is arched
over your head, a celestial
river of starlight,
and you are caught
between these two rivers,
and you are held in a beauty
that hinges on the juxtaposition
between harshness
and aestheticism.
It is an extraordinary thing,
it is a privilege and is a gift.
And I do have to admit
that encountering that
each and every night
is one of the closest things
that I've ever experienced
to true religion.
- I would say he may hate
my fraudulent photos,
but there are times that I
definitely wanted to stop
and his passion kept me going.
And we had to keep going.
The reality is we couldn't
soak up the starlight
like we wanted to,
we had to crawl out of our bags.
We descended into Olo Canyon,
this is how you
enter Olo Canyon,
it's one of the most
magnificent slot canyons
in all of Grand Canyon.
It's a 200-foot
repel, free repel.
You're cold and miserable,
but you have to come in here
and start your day
and find your way
through this remarkable maze.
I could've spent weeks in
here as a photographer,
it is total magic.
But the reality is,
like I said before,
we cached food every
distances apart,
we were on a 10-day
food line at this point,
and we have basically run out,
we have about a day's worth,
we're running down
to jelly beans,
and so we're in a race for food.
Here's a little snippet on that.
Got one day left of food.
Even though we're two days
away from our food cache.
- [Woman] Got it!
- What'd ya get?
- We're gonna eat again!
(screaming)
These are loaded baked potatoes.
- [Woman] Shut the front door.
Like chipotle?
- Yes!
So as it happens when
you camp or hike,
food becomes kind of important,
but we're now, once again,
happy and we've found
the Yellow Brick
Road, so to speak,
this is the Muav limestone
layer that we took
for a short distance,
about three river miles.
Kenton Grua, actually,
that Kevin featured in his book,
was the first person
to ever realize
you could connect these benches,
we're basically following
the black pellets of gold
we call them, the
bighorn sheep poop,
and we weaved our way
through here up to Mat Cat,
we climbed our way
back up from the river
back up onto the layer and then
weaved and ducked
and dived our way
all the way around
up into Havasu,
because we wanted to
really investigate,
you see these black lines here,
these black circles,
the uranium mines,
we want to try to
understand that issue.
- And the destination,
the endpoint of this segment,
the place that we were headed
was the kingdom of the people
of the blue-green water.
This is a very special
part of the Grand Canyon.
And it is home to the tiniest
tribe of Native Americans
who live either around
or inside the canyon,
the Havasupai people
who live inside of what
looks to be an idyllic home,
but they're
incredibly vulnerable
because one of the
things about the canyon
is that everything is connected
and so they are aware,
perhaps at a deeper level
than almost anyone else
just how vulnerable they are
to the sorts of things that
are happening right now
in the rim of the Grand Canyon.
- So this is the Havasupai
coming out to do a protest
in front of the canyon mine,
the canyon mine sits on the
south side of Grand Canyon,
it's out of the border
of the park itself,
but the Havasupai fear
that it's well within the
watershed of Grand Canyon
and if there were to be a
breach or anything would happen,
that it would flow
down right into
their water source, their life.
I spent time with
the uranium miners,
all guys trying to hang
on and do their job best,
they're doing
everything legally,
it's a contentious area,
a lot of people are
against uranium mining,
the challenge here is
nobody has the money
to drill a 3,000-foot
well to monitor
these mines and if they're
acting appropriately or not.
They're dealing with systems,
environmental regulations
that are not meant
for the Grand Canyon,
there's only one Grand Canyon.
And if you get above
this and start to see
the proximity, this
is on the north side,
this is Arizona 1 mine.
This is outside of
the park boundary,
but as you can see from the air,
everything is connected, it's
well within the watershed.
So if anything were to go wrong
in a uranium situation,
it would go right down into
the lifeline of the Southwest.